let's get right to CBS News chief
medical correspondent dr. Jon LaPook who
joins us now dr. LaPook the trends are
very clear and now we have States trying
to reverse them by reimposing
restrictions or slowing their reopening
how quickly might we see a reversal with
the numbers coming down again good
morning Tony we'll remember that there's
a 2 to 14 day incubation period so even
if everybody stops being infected today
you're gonna have people who were
infected over the last two weeks and
you're gonna start seeing those cases
trickle out in the next week or two but
after a week or two you'll see that
little lag the cases should start to go
down and you know the reality is that
this holiday weekend many businesses
will open their doors are going to want
to do it they know people want to come
in for four things in Fort Worth Texas
the owner of the rail club live bar is
defying orders there he told our Dallas
Fort Worth station KTVT why he plans to
host a 4th of July party get this weird
position right hours and if you do
damned if you don't right we do it and
we get in trouble and we roll the dice
let's see what happens there but we
don't do it we starve to death we lose
everything
so that's the position we're not doing
this to be mean anybody or caused
problems our back is against the wall
it's definitely a tough position to be
in now that bar owner says they will
require masks and social distancing so
John the question to you is is that
enough to make it safe and prevent the
spread of this virus indoors you know
nothing's 100% in terms of any of these
matters measures and the Devils in the
details Tony
so outdoors is safer than indoors if
you're in a restaurant I would have a
lot of qualms about doing that
especially if it's indoors everything
has to go right there are so many
different variables social distancing
what about the waiters or the are
they're coming right up to your they
taking their orders what's the
ventilation ventilation indoors is so
important so I mean for me this weekend
I'm telling everybody to stay home I
understand there are economic
consequences to it but you know our
country has done things that are a lot
harder
than this my father was a World War 2
vet and may he rest in peace but I'm
sure if he was alive he would say you
know something wearing a face mask doing
social distancing is nothing it's a walk
in the park compared to the Battle of
the Bulge yeah you're telling people to
stay home the Houston Chronicle on its
front page urging residents of that city
to stay home young people seem to be
taking on this message at a lower rate
than older people understandably they
seem to be less at risk of complications
themselves however they can infect other
people so what's your message to young
people who may not be taking this
seriously you know people think they're
immortal when they're that age young
people can get sick but I think the
bigger picture is one of society I mean
do we really have to say hashtag don't
kill grandma that's what we're talking
about I don't want to put guilt on
anybody but I think we people have to
realize there are consequences to
getting infected and spreading it to
people who are vulnerable they can die
this is something where as a society we
have to be together on I don't think we
should be shy about guilt guilt as a
powerful motivator people should ask
themselves how will they feel if they
contract it and then pass it on to
somebody else we've heard dr. Anthony
Fauci talk about these spikes that we
detailed calling them disturbing where
do you see the country going if this is
if we don't change direction you know I
spoke to Tony Fauci about 25 minutes ago
and he is very very concerned 50 percent
you know taking care of 50 percent of
the country in terms of lock down or
being very careful it's just not enough
when you look at Europe it was way over
90% of people who followed the plan
everybody was on the paint same page
there or rowing in the same direction
whatever the metaphor is but Europe went
up and down Asia up and down people were
wearing masks like they're supposed to
here I have faith in America's ability
to do great things I really do I think
we can all do this together but
everybody has to have one unified
message it can't be well anything having
to do with politics whether you're
Republican or Democrat we all should
have one goal here and that's to try to
flatten this curve get it down and by
the way once you get the cases down
let's say we were all inside for 14 days
and everybody
masks and and especially in places of
the country where we know that there are
cases if everybody stayed inside then it
would go down dramatically and we would
be able to do the contact tracing that
could then start to be effective where
we can find people who are infected find
their contacts and isolate them that's
how people have done in other countries
and we can do it here but we just have
to have the resolve to do it even if
it's painful to do it yeah dr. Jon
LaPook with a very clear message today
stay home if you can this weekend and
stay safe thank you very much for
joining us this morning